Whether you're a diehard Game of Thrones fan
or a casual viewer, it's fun to hunt for any
clues you can find from episode to episode.
And the eighth and final season is no exception.
Here's a look at many of the Game of Thrones
details you missed in the last six episodes
of the series.
One of the most unexpected moments of the
eighth season premiere actually came in the
show's opening credits, which features an
entirely new sequence with plenty of Easter
eggs.
The most notable change came right at the
start, with a reminder that the Wall that
once protected the Seven Kingdoms from the
threat of the White Walkers has been breached,
thanks to the Night King's brand-new zombie
dragon at the end of last season. The introduction
also added Last Hearth, an abandoned Northern
castle formerly home to the Umber family,
who were loyal to the Starks…right up until
they were all slaughtered by wights.
The map even shows us the path that the White
Walkers took to the climactic battle of Winterfell,
with the white tiles that made up the snowy
ground flipping to black to represent their
movement. After the climactic battle in "The
Long Night," though, those tiles stopped flipping,
indicating that the White Walkers are actually
finished after all. It's not just the events
of Season Eight that have left their mark
on Westeros, either. Images displayed on the
bands around the model sun depict past events
like the third season's infamous Red Wedding.
There's also an image of three dragons looking
at a comet, which represents the Red Comet,
said to fall when dragons appear, and which
made its own appearance in season two of the
show:
"That comet means one thing, boy: dragons."
Finally, in one of the coolest tweaks to the
opening sequence, the final episode shows
the damage that's been done to both Winterfell
and King's Landing. Like the actual city it
represents, the intricate clockworks that
raise the towers of the Red Keep on the map
have been broken, leaving the machinery stuttering
as it tries to raise them one last time.
The last time we saw Tormund Giantsbane and
Beric Dondarrion at the end of Season 7, they
were caught up in the Night King's first strike,
watching as he brought down the Wall. When
we finally get to check in with them in Season
8, they're tracking the destruction that the
White Walkers have left in their wake as they
traveled beyond the Wall, and they find a
pretty disturbing message left by the Night
King. The young Ned Umber, turned into a wight
and pinned to a wall amidst severed limbs,
provides the season's best jump scare when
he reawakens and has to be set aflame. It's
one of the most distressing images in the
series' recent memory, with Umber's dead body
at the center of a spiral pattern made up
of body parts, but it's not the first time
audiences have seen this pattern.
Since the very first episode of the show,
the White Walkers have long been associated
with spirals and circles, from arranging the
body parts of their victims to their sacred
place in the North and the cave drawings that
Jon showed Daenerys in the seventh season.
Perhaps most crucially, the spirals can be
seen in the scene that showed the Children
of the Forest creating the first Walker, suggesting
that these shapes have more to do with the
lore of the Walkers than viewers fully understand.
When audiences first met Theon Greyjoy, he
was arrogant and dismissive, especially to
Jon Snow, letting audiences know that perhaps
Theon needed to be taken down a peg.
"Right, give it here."
"I take orders from your father, not you."
Eight seasons later, and Theon's been brought
about as low as any character possibly could.
He's been psychologically broken from emotional
and physical torture, leaving him a beaten
man struggling to reclaim himself and fight
for a cause he believes in. After several
years of terrible behavior, Theon has fully
redeemed himself by saving Sansa's life and
proving that he's willing to sacrifice himself
to do the right thing.
Now, in the show's final season, Theon returned
to Winterfell to fight for the Starks, even
though his sister, Yara, set off to retake
the Iron Islands. In doing this, Theon's journey
has come full circle. After starting out with
the Starks before abandoning them, he has
finally come home to stand with them one last
time, completing the arc of one of the show's
most troubled characters.
"You're a good man."
Before she used it to put a permanent end
to the army of the dead, Arya's Valyrian steel
dagger already had a pretty notable history.
It was first seen in the show's second episode,
when it was used in an attempt to murder Bran
Stark after his fall from the tower, but it
really belonged to Littlefinger himself, Lord
Petyr Baelish. From there, it stayed with
Littlefinger until he gave it back to Bran,
who gave it to Arya, who, naturally, used
it to execute Littlefinger during his season
7 trial.
During the episode's big climax, as the Night
King makes his way towards Bran, Arya's training
helps her silently moves through the Godswood
until she gets to the Night King himself,
destroying him with Littlefinger's dagger
to save the brother who gave it to her. This
knife has had quite the journey where Bran
is concerned, so it seems oddly fitting that
the weapon once intended to kill him is what
saved not just him, but every human fighting
at Winterfell.
Cersei spent the Battle of Winterfell waiting
out her enemies, so when they finally arrive
at King's Landing to try to force her surrender,
she was ready to strike.
"Maybe Cersei will win and kill us all. That
would solve our problems."
Before the fight began, though, she had one
last brutal insult to hand down to Daenerys
and her forces. After her assault on Daenerys'
ships near Dragonstone, Cersei captures Missandei,
Daenerys' translator, confidante, and best
friend, and it's immediately clear that Cersei
will use her hostage however she has to in
order to achieve her bottom line.
"If you have any last words, now is the time."
In a brutal display of power, Cersei orders
the beheading of poor Missandei, who gives
her life willingly for her chosen queen, bravely
standing in support the woman who freed her
from her chains. However, Cersei's decision
to decapitate Missandei wound up having much
larger consequences than she realized. It
was one of the final things that drove Daenerys
over the edge, leading directly to the destruction
of King's Landing, and to Cersei having a
couple tons of bricks dropped on her head.
She shouldn't have been surprised, though:
the last time a blonde Lannister ruler vindictively
cut off someone's head to prove a point, it
was Joffrey ordering Ned Stark's execution,
the act that kicked off seven long years of
warfare and prestige television. In the final
days before her death, Cersei became as sadistic
as her terrible son.
As one of the only substances that can destroy
a White Walker, Valyrian steel can be tough
to come by. As a result, only a small handful
of characters on Thrones are in possession
of weapons made out of it. One of those characters
was Ned Stark, longtime Warden of the North
and Lord of Winterfell and unfortunately short-lived
Hand of the King to Robert Baratheon, whose
family sword was a massive piece of Valyrian
steel called Ice. After the honorable but
naïve Ned figured out that Prince Joffrey
wasn't Robert's biological son, he ended up
losing his head, and Ice was melted down and
remade into two new blades.
The first, christened Widow's Wail by Joffrey,
was barely used before Joffrey met his own
untimely end. It ended up with Jaime, his
uncle-slash-father.
"You said my father was my father, but my
uncle is my father. My father is my uncle!"
The second sword, Oathkeeper, was gifted to
Brienne of Tarth. Though Jaime and Brienne
spent some time on opposing sides of the conflict
between the Lannisters and the North, they
joined forces again during the Battle of Winterfell.
As they fought side by side, the two parts
of Ned's sword came together once again to
defend House Stark, which feels perfectly
fitting.
"It's reforged from Ned Stark's sword. You
will use it to defend Ned Stark's daughter."
Davos Seaworth might seem prickly at times,
but his soft side always showed around Shireen
Baratheon, daughter of the late Stannis Baratheon.
Shireen was afflicted by greyscale as a baby,
and while healers were able to stop the progression
of the disease, she still bore its scars on
her face, making her somewhat of an outcast.
This bonds her to Davos, especially when he's
imprisoned by Stannis for turning against
his king. While he's in captivity, Shireen
teaches Davos how to read, and the two end
up forming a real bond. When Davos discovers
later that Shireen has been sacrificed by
Melisandre to help Stannis' cause, he's understandably
devastated.
With that in mind, it's easy to see why Davos
and Gilly, who also learned to read thanks
to Shireen, were particularly struck by a
young, brave girl with a scarred face who
says she wants to fight alongside the soldiers
in Winterfell. To drive the emotional point
home, music associated with Shireen even plays
over the scene, reminding viewers of the young
princess and her tragic, untimely end.
Considering that he held the position of Master
of Whispers, it's no surprise that Lord Varys,
also known as "the Spider," trafficks in secrets.
It's what he's best at, and what he continued
to do right up until the very end of his life.
Having spent time with Daenerys' father, the
Mad King, he was understandably wary of the
Dragon Queen's quick temper and stubborn attitude,
something that he brought up with Tyrion in
a conversation that led to him being executed
as a traitor.
"Each of us has a choice to make. I pray we
choose wisely."
Varys doesn't plot against Daenerys for long
before he's taken to the beaches of Dragonstone
and executed by her last living dragon, Drogon,
during the penultimate episode of the series.
It shouldn't come as a surprise, however,
that he had a backup plan in place to stop
Dany himself. Before he's hauled off by the
guards, he has a a cryptic conversation with
a servant girl about the fact that Daenerys
isn't eating. In hindsight, it's easy to look
at this as the subtle indication of a last-ditch
effort by Varys to stop Dany before she can
launch her attack on King's Landing. It's
possible that he was using one of the show's
favorite methods of assassination, trying
to poison Daenerys before she can follow in
her father's footsteps. In the end, her grief
over Missandei and one of her dragons kept
Daenerys safe from eating anything that Varys
may have meddled with, and King's Landing
paid the price.
One of the most shocking moments on the series
came when Gregor Clegane, better known as
"The Mountain," faced off in trial by combat
against Oberyn Martell. Despite being stabbed
repeatedly, the Mountain ended that fight
by knocking Oberyn down one last time and
squeezing his head until it exploded. Oberyn's
spear was poisoned, however, and the Mountain
was given what should've been a fatal dose
of Manticore Venom.
"That's not how it ends for you, brother.
You know who's coming for you. You've always
known."
Fortunately for the Mountain, and unfortunately
for almost everyone else, he managed to stick
around thanks to Cersei's personal Dr. Frankenstein,
Qyburn. He didn't just become a mindless reanimated
corpse, though. If you need any evidence that
there was still at least a little bit of the
Mountain in that massive, horrifying body,
it's that, like all the best fighters, he
still uses his patented finishing move.
When he finally showed up for the long-anticipated
showdown that fans called "CleganeBowl," it
seemed like the Mountain's little brother
Sandor, nicknamed the Hound, was going to
meet a similar fate. No sword wound could
take down the Mountain, and sure enough, the
Hound got locked into the elder Clegane's
skull-crushing finale. This time, however,
that signature move doesn't guarantee victory.
The Hound overcomes his fear of fire and sends
them both tumbling over the ramparts of the
Red Keep, finally getting an appropriate revenge
for when the Mountain, as a child, shoved
the Hound into a fire and left him scarred
for life.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one.